well johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health they
are the uh font of excellent medical
advice and public health policy i would
think can i ask you a question i've
always wondered why is it john's does
anybody else have a hopkins
it's not it's not a possessive there's
no apostrophe i don't care how
possessive he is i just want to know how
he got one and if anybody else can
oh my god
yep
i will yes
i don't even know
uh show me screen for a second exactly
or for a little more than a second
here's the
i'm on there i'm still on a number of
these email lists where i get the
announcements from
oregon state health authority and johns
hopkins and maybe the cdc about what
they you know the state of the world
with the guard the state of oregon the
state of whatever uh with regard to
covet and uh
sorry's covey 2 the covet 19 situation
report that arrived in my inbox two days
ago november 4th
has this little nugget
uh it's got a lot of nuggets
under the heading u.s authorizes
pediatric vaccine
we have this
concerns remain over whether children in
this age group will be at risk of
myocarditis and pericarditis
inflammation of the heart muscle or
tissue surrounding the heart
respectively rare but potentially
serious adverse events associated with
the pfizer bioentec and moderna mrna
vaccines
the risk is highest among adolescent and
young adult males aged 12 to 29 years
and experts agree the risk in younger
children likely will be lower
what on what basis
why would you possibly think that
what we know
is that myocarditis and pericarditis
is an adverse event that is affecting
yes not very many but
many more than were expected
young men specifically
12 to 29 years old why 12 because that's
the age at which the vaccines are
allowed to begin
until it was 12 to 17 12 to 29 year olds
it was presumably 18 to 29 year olds
because the 12 to 17 year old
authorization came later
experts agree the risk in younger
children likely will be lower are they
[ __ ] kidding me i'm sorry like are
they kidding no you go ahead curse away
it's afternoon the kids are in bed
how do they get away with this garbage i
know experts agree the risk in younger
children likely will be lower on what
basis right it's like uh if we were to
survey people and figure out how many
words they had in their vocabulary and
we were to find out that they had fewer
and fewer words the younger they got and
then in the infants were expecting a
very large vocabulary experts agree
infants can probably speak a lot and
then they lose it before they relearn
all of their languages exactly
yeah it's preposterous experts agree
follow the science
follow the science we have an epidemic
in which people don't believe in truth
right
no i mean it's look it's it's a it's an
alice in wonderland nonsense world in
which uh who was it was they had the fda
was telling us that masks were 80
percent effective
and
uh
and then francis collins is telling us
that ivor mektin is putting people in
the hospital from overdosing and i mean
it's a it's a nonsense upside down world
and at some point at some point when
some system has given you enough really
lame answers that you can figure out are
just not right you have to stop
listening to it yes especially when it's
a health system it's not like this is
you know um
guidance on how to get cheaper cable
this is like how to stay alive and these
people are not good at it
no they're not i mean they may
personally be good at but they're not
good at giving you advice that will help
you do it
i wonder as you have
what medical
uh
advice they themselves are living by
yeah i would imagine they have very high
quality
advice but it's probably too complex for
commoners or something that's probably
true
[Music]